This episode is sponsored by Awesome Socks Club,
a sock subscription for charity. Click
the link in the description to sign
up between now and December 11th to get a
new pair of fun socks each month in 2021.
For all of us on the Microcosmos team, Stentors
are the gift that is always giving. They were
the first organism we did a deep dive
episode on because we wanted more people
to get a chance to appreciate how magnificent
this very unappreciated unicellular organism is.
And now with our fancy new DIC microscope, we’ve
gotten the chance to appreciate their magnificence
in new ways. It is amazing how changing bits
of light can give you a new perspective.
Scientists have been studying Stentors for well
over a century, and that’s given them plenty of
time to find new ways to learn about them. And
sometimes those methods are pretty normal. For
example, in 1995 there were reports that a lake
in Germany had turned black. And there was a clear
culprit: a large number of Stentor amethystinus.
And for one group of scientists, this “black-spot”
bloom was an opportunity to put their plankton
nets to good use and collect some samples.
They gathered the Stentor amethystinus
particularly to study the purplish
pigment amethystin that gives the species its
name, isolating the molecule so they could
determine its structure and compare it to other
pigments. The coloring is unique among stentors,
and it stands out particularly when you compare
it to the vivid blue of Stentor coeruleus.
Stentor coeruleus gets its color
from a pigment called stentorin,
which helps the stentor respond to light and
also serves a defensive function. And while
Stentor coeruleus is a much-studied organism,
this pigment has turned up in strange places.
In the mid-2000s, people began observing that
the blue catfish of Eufaula Lake in Oklahoma were
producing some strange eggs. Nothing was wrong
with them, but they were a reddish purple color.
Roughly a quarter of the female catfish were
laying purple eggs instead of their normal
yellowish cream-colored eggs. And when scientists
investigated further, they found that the ovaries
of the female catfish had become purple as well.
All that color came from stentorin. The lake had
likely experienced blooms of Stentor coeruleus,
which accumulated in the lake after the release
of organic pollutants. As the Stentor’s
numbers increased, so did their consumption
by the catfish. And that then drove to the
accumulation of stentorin inside the catfish’s
ovaries, affecting the color of the eggs.
Stentor coeruleus’s color makes it easy to spot,
but other species can be more difficult to tell
apart. We’ve labeled this one Stentor roeseli,
but to be completely honest, we’re
not sure if that’s exactly what it is.
It might be a similar looking species called
Stentor magnus, but we can’t tell them apart
just by looking at them. If we had a Stentor
magnus and a Stentor roeseli side-by-side,
we could not tell you just by looking at
them whether they were the same organism.
There is, however, a weird and gruesome way to
solve that mystery. It’s called grafting. To
start, you take your two mystery stentors and you
cut them in half. Then you quickly take half of
stentor number one and press it to half of stentor
number 2 at the exposed edge of both organisms.
Because they’re stentors and amazingly good at
regeneration, the two halves will fuse together,
like a “Frankenstein’s microbe.”
If your two original stentors
are the same species, that fusion will
survive. If they’re two different species,
most likely it will die. Though intrepid stentor
stitches have found that the degree to which these
different halves are incompatible varies with
different species and different combinations.
And we don’t know for certain which ones
will work, just that it’s a thing that
maybe we should test out ourselves one day.
Underlying grafting is that remarkable
regenerative ability of Stentors, which we’ve
described at length before. But to summarize:
stentors are just really good at rebuilding
themselves when they need to. Maybe you’re looking
at this unicellular organism and thinking, “Well,
it’s just one cell, how complicated can it be?”
Pretty complicated, it turns out! So
complicated that we still don’t really
know how this regeneration works. Scientists have
been trying to figure this out for over a century,
and the mystery remains unsolved though at
this point at least very well-documented.
And for more than a century, scientists have
been passing down techniques to cut stentors
into pieces. There’s the obvious surgical
technique, using a needle to cut a stentor
into pieces and then watch it reconstruct
several new versions of itself. But you can
also bathe stentors in a sugar solution, and the
organism will then shed its oral apparatus (which
is its version of a mouth). It’s not clear why
this happens, but it allows scientists to watch
the stentor rebuild that one portion of its body.
Scientists used this method to study how Stentor
coeruleus resets the movement of its cilia after
regenerations. Cilia may look like little bits of
hair lining the organism, but they act more
like a coordinated set of limbs that help
draw in food and move the stentor around. Lots
and lots of limbs that are moving together in a
complex dance that in turn creates patterns of
movement in the water surrounding the stentor.
And the scientists watched as the stentors
were able to rebuild this whole complex
system again. They found that it takes about 5
hours just to grow those oral cilia back to an
observable length, and then another two hours for
the cilia to start coordinating their movements.
So much work went into understanding the timeline
of this one narrow process in regeneration,
and there is still so much mechanical
mystery underlying it. Not to mention all
the other feats of regenerative prowess that
stentors casually perform on a regular basis.
But science is always advancing. And with
all these mysteries to solve and more,
stentors will likely find
themselves at the center of many
many other strange experiments
and observations to come.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
Now I’m gonna go out on a limb here and assume
that you, person listening to this, wear socks
sometimes. And what if I told you that you could
get new socks while also giving to charity?
Well, that’s precisely what the Awesome Socks Club
is all about. It’s a charity sock subscription
where 100% of after-tax profit will go to decrease
maternal and child mortality in Sierra Leone.
The socks are fun and attractive and
subscribers will get a different pair
designed by a different designer every month
of 2021. But so we can control inventory and
reduce waste, sign up are only going
to be available until December 11th.
So if this sounds like a club
you’d like to be a part of,
head on over to awesomesocks.club/microcosmos
to sign up, or just click the link in
the description, and remember you
have to sign up by December 11th.
Thank you as always to all of these people here.
They are our Patrons. They make it possible
for us to make content like this for everyone
who wants to see it. If you’d like to join up
with them and also get some cool little perks,
you can check out patreon.com/journeytomicro.
If you want to see more from our
Master of Microscopes James Weiss,
check out Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us there’s
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.